tonight an outpouring of support for a
north las vegas cyclist hit and killed
31 year old benjamin black died
yesterday morning police say an suv hit
black on his bike near north 5th and the
215 they say speed was a factor jeremy j
ford speaking with residents in the area
who are shocked about what happened in
their quiet neighborhood
[Music]
i'm here at the intersection of darrell
and boston weir the site of the bicycle
accident where residents tell me that if
drivers don't slow down there could
possibly be more injuries
i have come out of my own side street
and had to kind of like see my speed and
correct myself david who lives in this
area tells me since the accident
neighbors have been just concerned
really
concern for the person the bicyclists
that got hit concerned for the person
that was behind the wheel
just overall levar taylor lives a block
away from where it happened and says on
his block speeding usually isn't a
problem we're not on a residential
street at the moment so i mean you know
slow down while you're coming through
here
the same message echoed by north las
vegas police chief jacqueline gravad the
entire valley is growing therefore the
population is going to increase that's
only going to mean more vehicles on the
road and we want all of our citizens to
be safe with these words of advice from
david the concerned resident be careful
when you're driving and as you're
driving just try to be aware of your
surroundings in north las vegas jeremy j
ford live local now